what up YouTube just got a at a stage at
a stage off the [ __ ] stage here in my
green room and wanted to really tell you
that I felt really great about this
keynote that you're about to watch here
in Washington DC actually in Virginia
actually said DC insiders like do you
see there's like I said you'll see me
say DC but later Virginia really excited
about it a lot of mindset strategy stuff
in a lot of details in the opportunity
and just one more hard squeeze to the
neck of the opportunity we're all living
in right now and two more shots to the
neck number one if you're not subscribed
and I just looked at it and most of you
watching this right now are not
subscribed it would mean the world to me
to give a little subscribe to the
channel because we're pumping out a ton
of good content in the video experience
and number two first in line first in
line first in line I'll leave a a link
in the copy if you do not know what
burst in line is it means you have not
signed up for it it is my text message
and facebook Messenger CRM system we're
basically all my coolest [ __ ] goes to
first I want you to be a part of that
please sign up
[Applause]
put up
but up thank you thank you thank you
thank you sir
let's get every minute in here I love
you I see you I can hear let's go thank
you so much
thrilled to be here DC area excited want
to talk about a bunch of things today
but I really want to focus on the
mentality and then the execution the
biggest thing that I've realized over
the last decade is that people break
into two different camps they either get
really mindset oriented motivation
oriented education oriented come to
conferences like this consume a ton of
content get really up here and then the
break down to why it hasn't happened
comes in the actual execution then
there's people who are doing and
executing and making and producing
content starting a business executing
executing executing but their mindset is
broken or more importantly when I think
about it
one of the biggest things that I think
is not clicking is they really don't
have it figured out from the finish line
standpoint I was saying in an earlier
session I just had that one of the
biggest things that I find fascinating
is that if I was analyzing myself and II
can't get up here right here I got you I
see you and he's live-streaming and he's
struggling let's give it up for Andy Kay
right here's good and you get nice and
close good job [ __ ] I lost my thought
Andy
I got it I got I'm kidding I'm kidding
it's it's really interesting I was
saying in a session right before that if
I was analyzing what I've done in
business for the last decade I would
actually have a lot of issues with it if
I read it on paper and didn't know who I
was lacking the context what was I
trying to achieve over the last decade
I've left an enormous amount of
economics on the table done business
deals that I think a lot of people in
this room would deem as not a good deal
not the right move if you didn't know
that I was trying to buy the New York
Jets they would seem stupid if you did
they would make a ton of sense I think
one of the things that people have to
ask themselves here both on a personal
level as a human and then on a
professional level of what are you
trying to achieve is do you actually
even understand what your finish line
looks like so many people are caught up
so many people here unhappy because
they're just living to pay for the box
and the container they've made for
themselves by buying that house or that
car or that thing just literally stuck
because they put themselves in that
position oftentimes to keep up with the
Joneses but often because they just
don't know real quick I'll get right
back to my keynote but I have to make a
reference here real quick you guys
cuddling under that blanket is the
greatest [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever seen in
my life
it's not that [ __ ] cold you guys are
[ __ ] soft
I mean if you think it's cold in here
you've got no chance of winning out
there get your [ __ ] game up guys I
was born in [ __ ] Russia it's not that
[ __ ] pull down there get out of here
that American [ __ ] alright listen listen
I love it
guys listen I think what I love about
this is the interaction we're doing
right now this is the best I love the
stage what I hate about it is I don't
have context on you one by one right
what I what I love about meeting with
somebody individually or knowing Andy
who works with me is by having the
context I can actually get to those
subtle little pieces went onstage I've
got to keep it macro I try to go micro
but I know that everybody here has
different [ __ ] here's what I can tell
you a couple things that really make
sense to me in a macro talk something
that I know is fundamentally universal
for everybody there they are they're
there anybody in this room one thing
that I know is fundamentally universal
is that nobody is gonna cry for you they
have their own tears one thing one thing
I'm positive about is how ROI negative
complaining is and how much I'm trying
to suffocate the practice of it I really
have been fascinated by people that have
changed their mindset into understanding
that everything that is not going well
right now is their fault it has been
remarkably important to me in
understanding that everything that I'm
not happy about has is on me
it's it's a remarkably interesting brain
twist the amount of energy spent on
things that you can't control versus
being accountable to what you can
control has been a huge separator for me
in the last four or five years as I've
dug deep and so of course there are
things that have happened to
you that you can't control but if you
were able to leave if I was able to have
a couple things happen out of this talk
this morning one is just self-awareness
just like do you actually know who you
are so many people wishing there's
something instead of understanding what
they are
number two is accountability no question
the quickest way to happiness is
accountability when people start looking
for somebody else to be at fault whether
it's the government or their aunt or
some or their [ __ ] boss they always
lose the energy really matters and so
I've been thinking a lot about mindset
I've also been thinking about passion a
lot more recently even though the first
book I wrote was a lot about your hobby
or your niche is your power ironically
I've come back to it I've given a lot of
thought to what makes you tick and how
realistic is the long tail of the
Internet to get there I am stunned by
how many people here don't realize that
the quickest path to happiness or more
economics in business given the context
of this talk happens to be in the thing
that they love the most yet they're not
willing to eat [ __ ] for the next three
to five years to get there let me
explain it blows me away that if you're
ridiculously passionate about the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles now stick
with me I know this is going [ __ ]
weird that starting your Instagram
account your podcast and your YouTube
channel about Leonardo and Michelangelo
and putting out that content for a
three-year period in the long tail of
the Internet in the way that niche
marketing works if you focus on that
7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
around that world that literally within
three to four years the practicality if
you're consistent to making between
fifty and a hundred thousand dollars a
year in affiliate fee Bay links and
sponsorship around being the foremost
expert of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
is a very fascinating thing now that may
be a very rogue example for a lot of
people in this room but I'm desperate
for you to understand that if your
passion and knowledge is around eating
and living vegan if it's around sneaker
culture if it's around fashion or peanut
butter or whatever it may be you need to
leave this conference and debate one
thing the most fascinating time of day
for me right now in the world is 7:00
p.m. to 2:00 in the morning you would
not be at this conference if you were
100% there you would not be here if you
were 100% there that's just facts so now
I'm curious about how many people don't
see the world that I see it was funny
Andy and I on the way here saw a video
that I'm gonna post you'll see on my
social very soon that we dug up from
2011 where I basically tell everybody to
invest in Amazon right I go everybody's
talking about Facebook and Google and
Apple but weirdly I think Amazon 2011
people didn't realize how big Amazon was
and it's interesting when I look back at
them like [ __ ] I said that seven years
ago what did I see it's the same feeling
I have right in here when I look in the
fit you know what's so great is I can
see your face right now and just
realizing how many people are chasing
money you know how many people here and
across this country right now rushed to
buy cryptocurrency because that's where
the gold rush was I'm just fascinated by
people's passion for the quick fix
versus the marathon I'm fascinated by
people willing to put [ __ ] in their body
to lose 15 pounds that's some private
label horseshit from China versus
[ __ ] eating right and exercising
let me let me promise you something good
and that's how I want to say it
everything special is [ __ ] hard
that's very true right it is true I
don't understand you know what I find
funny that this collective room and when
I say this room I mean this whole
[ __ ] country doesn't realize the
following data point which is that if
you make four hundred forty thousand
dollars a year in income you are in the
1% that in America one of the richest
countries in the world the top 1% starts
at four hundred forty thousand a year a
lot of money however everybody is
walking around right now talking like if
they're if they're not making a million
that's just like the entry point to
making it we are completely missing
perspective of what's going on out there
we're missing perspective people are
fundamentally confused of how hard it is
to be at that place and by the way let's
talk about real privilege forget about
money how about this when are we gonna
start talking about the mindset and the
happiness of it all so for me what the
Internet represents the reason I get
passionate somebody sent a great tweet
today about my being in line at this
conference and they saying they were
they said the people in front of them
were talking about me and the one person
said he's good at Facebook and the other
person said oh [ __ ] I thought he was in
real estate and I was laughing I was
laughing because what's really
interesting is I'm an entrepreneur in a
time where entrepreneurship got cool how
many people over 35 raise your hand all
right so all these old [ __ ] for all
the kids in here they all know a world
where entrepreneurship wasn't cool just
for all the kids how many people under
30 raise your hands
[Applause]
by the way I [ __ ] love people under 30
so much
[Applause]
can we please use this conference to
stop the hating on Millennials please
seriously I love how my friends an older
act like we didn't have lazy [ __ ] in
our generation either honestly um I
genuinely believe the millennial
generation and I watch very carefully is
literally the most unstoppable except
for one thing the biggest under 30 raise
your hands
honestly you've got this the only thing
you have to promise me is you have to
understand one thing about business and
life that you have a disadvantage of you
haven't been punched in the face yet
it's true the only thing that is your
your vulnerability isn't the entitlement
and all the other [ __ ] that everybody
else says we've had plenty entitlement
and [ __ ] in America for a long time your
biggest problem is you haven't been
punched in the [ __ ] face yet since
you've been grown and in the game the
economy has been phenomenal over 40
raise your hands us [ __ ] been punched
a couple of times we were you in 2007
when we thought we were [ __ ] fresh
until the economy got its [ __ ] ass
kicked the only vulnerability you have
is you think putting entrepreneur in
your profile means you're an
entrepreneur
[Music]
so couple things number one if you're
not winning right now during nine years
and don't get it twisted it's the nine
years of economic growth nine years of
economic growth if you're not winning
now after nine years of economic growth
after we got bailed out and we didn't
want to pay the piper well then you
[ __ ] suck and I want to stay on this
for a minute if you think you're an
entrepreneur and you've got a business
and you've been doing it for more than
two years and you're not successful
during a fake propped-up bailed out
economy after nine years of growth
you're not good now maybe what you're
trying to build is not good and you are
good and you just missed it this time
but I need everybody to take a real
reality step backwards because I listen
I'm here for one agenda I'm selfish yeah
I am I'm selfish in the fact that Caleb
were you at know Caleb you film in Ghana
can't find you Andy where's Caleb
how the [ __ ] can you get up there I'm
selfish for Caleb who's filming today's
vlog and for Andy I'm here to be
historically correct I'm here to be
historically correct so when I stand up
here and say if you're not successful in
your business and you've been doing it
for two years on nine years of economic
growth that have been propped up by
[ __ ] a bailout that you suck I'm not
saying that cuz I think I'm fancy up
here I don't like that doesn't that
doesn't mean no good that's not
interesting I'm saying it because you
have to be self-aware happiness comes
from self-awareness the number 19 at
Facebook made a lot more than every
other number one of every startup period
there's a lot of people right now that
wanna put entrepreneurship and owning
their own thing on a pedestal because
it's cool now just like Harvard it used
to be cool 20 years ago and just like I
didn't fall for that plenty people here
I don't want the fall for the
Entrepreneurship thing how many people
here are entrepreneurs so raise them
high I want to see it one more time you
got that you got that down so for
everybody raising their hand one more
time I apologize I just want you to look
around let me promise you one thing that
all the people with their hand up know
this [ __ ] is lonely how many people work
somewhere raise your hands it's cool
love it let me tell you the best part
about working somewhere you get to blame
somebody else what sucks about
entrepreneurship one more time hands
entrepreneurs everything wrong with your
business right now is your [ __ ] fault
how many people here have more than five
employees raise your hand
every employee you blame you [ __ ]
hired them dick
[Applause]
every single thing wrong with your
business is your [ __ ] fault that's
what sucks about entrepreneurship the
other thing that sucks is when the
economy does correct properly and ninty
let me say it one more time hands up
ninety percent of these people go out of
business that [ __ ] hurts when you
have to go get a job and everybody makes
jokes about you changing your profile so
the glamour that we're putting on
entrepreneurship right now in a world
where more than ever people are scared
to have l's on their resume scares me
cuz that leads to depression that leads
to a [ __ ] up place I come here DC with
one agenda in mind which is I really
want to make sure that people leave here
knowing who they are
do you understand yourself do you
actually have a situation where you
judge yourself within yourself or do you
allow other people's opinions to dictate
your life there is nothing nothing more
difficult than navigating your life
based on somebody else's opinion and if
you really reverse-engineer so many of
your actions you will be devastated by
how much is being done based on somebody
else's opinions the great gift of my
life has been the evolution of my
process of not going there by going away
from it and how many people here are
parents of kids under 15 raise your
hands
let me just go on this high horse for 30
seconds all all the far majority all's -
absolutely the far majority of my
happiness today as a man is predicated
on all the adversity and losses I had in
the first 18 years of my life if there
is nothing that scares me more in our
society today its eighth place trophies
I don't like kids crying any more than
you but eighth place trophies and fake
environments and all this adversity that
we're trying to strip out of kids every
[ __ ] person in this room was bullied
in school we all took our elves
we all had a weird year or two all of us
some weirder than others not you Andy
but we need to start putting losses and
adversity on a pedestal not hiding it as
somebody who's really over-indexing on
Instagram and snapchat just back to
parents here real quick just real talk
something I've never said publicly if
you and your spouse are going through a
rough patch and you're fighting and it's
not on point and your kids are seeing it
and then you go to Disneyland and take a
photo with the family and make it seem
like everything is [ __ ] awesome
you're setting up your kids for some
terrible [ __ ] keep that in mind and you
can use that example for all the under
30s that may not have a family fronting
posturing or my favorite that all of you
bought in to fake it until you make it
look the [ __ ] part let me tell you
for all the homies that live life
looking the part for all you [ __ ] faces
wearing fake watches
and a suit that you can't afford because
somebody [ __ ] told you that you have
to look the part to win let me tell you
who you're fooling with your look the
part other [ __ ] losers the quickest
way for me to know somebody goes in the
L column for life is when they're faking
it until they make it it is absolute
horseshit out there right now because of
the way communication listen I'm all
about this this is the [ __ ] game if
you do not put your mobile device and
the platforms that are on it on a
pedestal
you were actually irrelevant in society
you don't like it cool I don't give a
[ __ ] it's still the truth especially for
this audience if you're in business if
you're making business decisions based
on you being angry at technology because
kids don't look each other in the eye
anymore if you're running your business
based on your ideology of how humans
should be interacting with each other
you will lose I love when people walk
into like my favorite is when you judge
when you walk into a restaurant and you
see a couple sitting there and they're
both on the phone and you like hit
you're partnering like oh that's so
terrible right like they're not even
talking you think that's so terrible I
think it's phenomenal
I'm being dead serious I think it's
phenomenal let me tell you why
especially for the over a 30 year old
crowd because they're gonna remember the
world this way back in the day kids when
people didn't have [ __ ] phones I saw
that same couple 15 years ago let me
tell you what they did they sat at
dinner across from each other and they
didn't say a [ __ ] word to each other
now at least they could be doing what
they actually want to be doing
my friends technology hasn't changed us
technology hasn't changed us
technology's exposing us everybody wants
you guys really love to blame the
Russians the Russians didn't go into
pole booth and [ __ ] pull the lever
you did dick let me tell you how
Facebook ads really run they put [ __ ] in
front of you that you're gonna respond
to we're getting exposed
we're not changed there's no Overlord
robot sucks is not controlling your
[ __ ] mind we just don't like being
accountable to anything accountability
my friends you put accountability on a
pedestal your life will change do you
know how liberating it is when you
realize everything's your fault it gets
real [ __ ] good out here when you
actually realize everything's your fault
it gets really good out here because
when you think your boss's boss controls
your [ __ ] when you think somebody down
the street in a building controls your
[ __ ] then you get real sad because you
feel helpless when you realize you
control your [ __ ] things [ __ ] go and
so now let me switch into what you can
do about it
now that we've established that mindset
thing if you do not understand that
Facebook Ads Facebook Ads so whoever was
in line saying he's good at Facebook
you're [ __ ] right if you do not
understand that Facebook Ads running ads
not posting organically on your page and
getting a couple likes running
advertising spending ten thirty eighty
nine hundred dollars on a post to a
specific group of people which is why
you made the video or picture in the
first place that has an agenda behind it
around your ambitions to be the mayor of
your town sell some [ __ ] sneakers or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do with
your life right this minute
[ __ ] August 22nd August 22nd to
18 right this minute right this minute
right this minute August 22nd 20 18
Facebook advertising and Instagram story
advertising is the most underpriced real
estate grab of human attention in
America ever period how many people here
have run Facebook ads and something good
has happened for their business raise
your hands how many people here have run
Facebook ads and something bad has it
just didn't work raise your hands
own it don't be a dick
Facebook and Instagram ads are no
different than a basketball the ROI of a
basketball for me is negative I've had
two meniscus tears and they cost me some
money the ROI of a basketball for LeBron
a billion Facebook Ads work if you're
sitting in this crowd and you're like
Facebook doesn't work Facebook Ads work
you just might not know how to play it
and if you don't go home from this
conference and sit down and Google and
YouTube and read and watch videos for 10
hours to learn a cult do you know many
people here have opinions on Facebook
Ads yet they've never run one if you do
not go home and learn how to run a
Facebook ad and then do it like within
24 hours if you do not leave this talk
and run a Facebook ad for your business
service or a ambition well then what are
we doing here you can't read about doing
push-ups you've got to do push-ups if
you are not producing content for
Instagram Facebook snapchat Twitter
LinkedIn YouTube these platforms if you
do not produce written words pictures or
audio or video for the 7 to 12 websites
the apps that dominate the attention of
America you have no shot of succeeding
to the level that you want because
either you are massively limit
you're upside or and this is the funny
part how many people feel like there how
many people are having their best
business year ever raise your hand raise
it high
first of all let's clap it up for them
one more time best year so far on one
more time hold it up I really want to
see the people my friends on some
serious [ __ ] you're the people that I'm
most worried about no I mean it I'm
being dead serious with you here's
what's happening it happened in 2001 to
2004 something came along it was called
Google people didn't know exactly how
powerful it really was a product call
came out called Google AdWords at first
Google just had results then these
little ads started showing up at first
they cost five cents a click I as a
young kid when I when they were doing my
bio which by the way who rolled my pot
my mom must have written that by those
[ __ ] ridiculous it's going a hunt for
that I was like and he sneezes on
Thursdays and he can we please [ __ ]
fix that it was way too long of a bio uh
sorry I was like just couldn't wait to
get out of he was like shut up
what's completely fascinating to me
about this is Google came along and when
Nate did my bio they said and he built
his dad's business from a three to sixty
million dollar business and some people
collapse one guy made of loud noise and
I'm literally back there and I'm like
leisure and the reason I said loser and
I said it and I say it every time
because that will always be in my bio
that's my origin story because that
should have been three to two hundred
fifty million and it should have been
three to two hundred fifty million
because I had figured out that moment in
time and it was called Google Adwords
I was buying every wine term you can
imagine for five and ten cents a click
and they were all working but I was too
young and I didn't fully understand what
was happening and I spent money on
direct mail and radio and print and
television and other internet [ __ ] and
wine
spectator calm and a magnitude of other
things how many people play poker when
you have the nuts you have them and
you're supposed to go all-in and I
didn't and I had them and then I went my
whole career did well did my thing but I
never had them and I have them now and
I'm trying to give them to you
it's called Facebook ads and Instagram
story ads they're the [ __ ] nuts let
me tell you exactly what's gonna happen
from this second on ninety eight point
nine percent of you are gonna get super
[ __ ] fired up by my keynote and then
next Thursday's gonna happen and some
shits gonna happen you're gonna lose a
client or something Bad's gonna happen
data and all the good vibes and energy
are gonna go away
and you're gonna go back to defense and
passive and not offense ninety eight
point nine percent of you are literally
not going to take the action that I'm
asking you to do which is figure out how
to convert your message to your ambition
whether you're a landscaper selling a
t-shirt whatever the [ __ ] dentist I
don't give a [ __ ]
the reason I say that is I don't give a
[ __ ] if you sell concrete wholesale this
[ __ ] is gonna work for you but you don't
believe me I'm serious I know I [ __ ]
do this is [ __ ] ground hogs day for
me I spit this [ __ ] selfishly you know
why in seven years I'm gonna run this
[ __ ] video and you're gonna see it
and be like [ __ ] I was there and you're
gonna and the videos gonna be like I
[ __ ] told you so
and it's gonna be a Wall Street Journal
article that in the year 2000 [ __ ] in
3rd 15 to 19 was the golden era of
Facebook cuz it only costs five to six
dollars CPM and $2 $3 CPMs on Instagram
and now they're 50 and $80 CPMs I know
it because I've seen this movie before
you know it's [ __ ] awesome about
being 42 and not 20 for context I have
context I [ __ ] lived it I seen it I
watched it I lived it do you know why
you know who Prince Madonna Michael
Jackson are besides their talent they
[ __ ] hack MTV when it owned the
attention you know who else [ __ ]
hacked MTV [ __ ] P Diddy you know why
P Diddy [ __ ] one he's to get out of
his ass in his office and run to TRL
when Carson was on and just go on set
uninvited cuz he knew every [ __ ]
teenager in America was watching and he
was stealing attention the attention is
one place you don't like it cool sorry
your grandparents didn't like Elvis
either
and people here judged Miley Cyrus eight
years ago for what she did at the VMAs
which now 8 years later is like a lame
Instagram post culture moves things move
we're sitting in a weird time ask me ask
me why I wasn't making a lot of content
in 2011 12 13 14 not thank you yes
I didn't mean ask me dicks calm down the
reason I wasn't making content was there
wasn't anything this ridiculous it was
business as usual Twitter Facebook
YouTube they were maturing there wasn't
anything special
it wasn't outrageous it wasn't a great
Buy you weren't buying Malibu beachfront
property you weren't buying Manhattan
you weren't buying great property it was
properly priced it wasn't under priced
every single person here regardless of
her or his ambition has one agenda to
get the potential person they want to
talk to attention and then they have to
talk and execute for their action we
have not seen a more remarkable
underpriced opportunity of people's
attention than we have right now
specifically on Facebook ads Instagram
stories YouTube pre-roll and podcast
advertising if you spend the next my
friends you can read every quote I put
on Instagram you can watch Tony's
documentary on Netflix 947 [ __ ] times
you can [ __ ] go on a retreat to an
island meditate [ __ ] hire me to
personally consult and sit by your by
the way your [ __ ] house that's fresh
and sit by you sit by your fresh outfit
for 24 hours a day and nothing I say for
the next month will be better than the
advice I'm giving you right now which is
figure out how you communicate you don't
need to be like me not everybody is
ridiculously charismatic and
good-looking on video
you might dominate writing you might be
embarrassed because of lighting or
makeup or just you're just insecure
visually fine
I'm not even judging I don't give a [ __ ]
audio that [ __ ] right draw pictures I
don't give a [ __ ] go on a [ __ ]
mountain and do smoke signals figure out
how to communicate on LinkedIn Facebook
Instagram snapchat these platforms
podcasts how many people here consume my
content raise your hand
thank you I know you know this I say it
all the time don't listen to what I'm
saying watch what I'm doing why am i
putting out content everywhere always at
a scale that has never been seen before
cuz I know it's a moment in time I
promise you if you find somebody who
bought a beachfront home in Malibu when
it was first coming up if you asked her
what she thought about that whole
situation the first things out of her
mouth was I wish I bought a second home
because that 300,000 became 40 million
there are moments when things are under
priced there are moments when things are
under priced the number one asset in the
world is other people's attention their
attention is in play it lives here here
are seven or eight platforms named
YouTube Facebook Instagram snapchat got
it you need to figure out how to be in
there let me give you another analogy
because analogies work the Internet is
basically the highway the information
superhighway was a perfect analogy back
in the day it is the highway to our
lives Facebook and Apple and Google they
were so good as companies they figured
out how to be the toll booth on those
highways every person in years job is to
become the best toll booth collector
inside that toll booth
[Applause]
there is no shortcut
there's no [ __ ] hashtag that you're
gonna find it's gonna [ __ ] explode
you are saying it was right what
actually works is the same [ __ ] that
works in everything in life running an
actual marathon life is long yes I know
you might get hit by bus good news if
you get hit by a bus you're not gonna
give a [ __ ] about anything please start
playing life is long do you know many
people emailed me and said Gary I need
your help I'm desperate I bought a ton
of [ __ ] Bitcoin at $15,000 a coin
everybody told me was gonna be a hundred
thousand i maxed all my credit cards
this that the other thing and I reply
I'm like why why'd you do that
and the answer is it's what always
happens there's always Gold Rush people
don't want to put in the work and I get
that like they have this imaginary thing
of like how good it's gonna be DeRozan
the basketball player for the Spurs who
just got traded from the Raptors had a
quote the other day I wish everybody was
rich so they realized how much happiness
or not it brings there's a lot of truth
to that
there's everybody's in a rush because
they don't realize that loving the
process is the game not the [ __ ] that
the process gives you
[Applause]
I make you the most guaranteed promise
ever if what you're doing for a living
right now is a means to the money you
[ __ ] lost you lost it's too hard to
get to the big money you have to love it
it's too hard because if you don't love
real estate but you're doing it cuz you
think that's where the money is the guy
or gal that loves real estate is gonna
beat your [ __ ] ass it's just the way
it is and what's interesting to me is
this is all happening when the imminent
internet has finally hit mass mass scale
it blows me away that you could go
literally buy apples apples wholesale
and relist them and make money I know
dude I want it I'm using this funny [ __ ]
for a reason I don't think people
realize here's what scares the [ __ ] of
me it's never been easier to make
$100,000 a year in America if you do the
following spend 50 hours I'm asking you
to spend 50 hour how about tell the
truth how many people here would be
happy to make $100,000 a year raise your
hand I want to see the hands raise them
higher because this matters so can you
stand this matters to me please stand
please this matters don't [ __ ] be
scared because I know people drunken oh
[ __ ] should be a million this is huge
for me I'm really happy that people are
being honest cuz a lot of people like
the front like no billion or bust stay
up listen to me this is more than 70% of
this room right now based on my eye test
maybe 65 that would be thrilled to make
a hundred I know how hard it is to make
a hundred
I'm gonna tell you something that's
gonna blow your [ __ ] face off and I
and I say this because I'm selfish
because I do think one of you that is
standing is gonna listen to me and do
this and then you're gonna email me in
24 months if you just spend fifty to a
hundred hours educating yourself on
something you like or no books sneakers
pants electronics something stuff we're
gonna talk about selling right now and
you study eBay and what the price it
goes for on eBay in Baia now's and
auctions buy it there and then send it
to Amazon and list on Amazon if you
spend 12 hours a day
after spending a hundred to two hundred
hours educating yourself on a genre
calculators blouses purses [ __ ] I
don't know that cup - [ __ ] paste if
you spend a hundred two hundred hours
understanding the arbitrage that this
sneaker sells for 450 on eBay but 580 on
Amazon and you figure out how to buy it
at enough scale in Asia or Europe or
you're buying wholesale in Sydney
Australia shipping to Amazon if you get
educated on what's called retail
arbitrage you can sit at home spend 10
hours a day working it like day trading
and I genuinely believe 50% which is
absurd 50% of the people standing will
hit their hundred thousand to me that's
crazy it's so practical it takes some
work like I told you but yet people you
could sit now thank you it's practical
it's practical 70 percent of this
audience wants to make a hundo I
genuinely know that if you have the
humility to eat [ __ ] for three years
downsize you know many people I wish
sold their home right now and went and
rented because that's the crutch or that
[ __ ] BMW that you have no reason
[ __ ] having but the only reason you
have it is because you want a front in
front of people you don't even like
if you have the humility and the work
ethic and the reason I want you to do it
around something you like is searching
calculators for 12 hours a day if it's
just for the money gets tedious and
you'll break unless you love calculators
searching puzzles because you [ __ ]
love puzzles for 15 hours a day isn't
tedious I'm telling you right now
literally I believe in this so much that
yesterday I know some of you follow me
on social media yesterday I spent seven
hours figuring out that I think Charles
Barkley 1986-87 FLIR rookie cards are
grossly underpriced in a 17-year window
and I'm gonna invest heavy so if you got
any Berkeley rookies great at nine and
above I'm interested that took me three
hours and I'm [ __ ] happy and said
that's how much I believe in the dirt my
friends if you want a hundo it's either
become the foremost expert in Snorks how
many people know what a snork is [ __ ]
Smurfs in the sea
everyday I just want everybody
understand every single day I get the M
by 15 people who are under 16 years old
who have the humility to stay in line at
sneaker stores and build their Instagram
and are making $10,000 a month in profit
flipping Yeezys and off lights and
Jordans this is America in 2018 there is
nothing but money out there the problem
is most people aren't self-aware to know
who they are instead of what they wish
they were and most people didn't find
something that they're willing to do for
18 hours a day because they're looking
for the money they're not looking for
what they love retail arbitrage or
building a media company a podcast a
youtube show an Instagram account around
a longtail niche for the next 24 to 36
months patience diligence less stranger
things marathons more studying Amazon
less [ __ ] fortnight more studying
eBay listen you could be ninja if you
want but and by the way it just comes
down to the level of happiness but I
know one thing when 70 percent stands up
for a hundo and I've never seen an era
that's easier to get to a hundo easy 15
hours a day 200 hours upfront but when
you [ __ ] audit the last 60 days of
your life and think about all the
[ __ ] leisure that you put in and how
that got to 200 hours real quick and
you're not totally pumped and you want
it so bad I'm [ __ ] giving you I'm
giving you the [ __ ] fishing pole
right now we watch this [ __ ] I'm giving
you the fishing pole the problem is most
of you don't want to walk down to the
lake and [ __ ] fish
apples vegan Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
sneakers everybody's talking about
billion dollar AI this machine learning
that cryptocurrency this and 70% of the
[ __ ] in here wanna make a hundo I
know you can do that by literally
picking up old VCRs on Craigslist and
flipping them on eBay but are you
discipline and humble and hungry enough
to get there that my friends comes when
you tune out everybody but yourself when
you're not worried if your friends are
judging you for buying cotton balls in
China and flipping it on Amazon you can
get there and I'm telling you right now
if any of your [ __ ] auntie or
grandmother or wife if any of these [ __ ]
faces judge you send them to me I'll
[ __ ] set them straight Virginia I
[ __ ] love you
[Applause]
let's go
with my hands
[Applause]